scenes of a United Ethiopian Orthodox
church after weeks of tension and unrest
visuals like this one in Adisa Baba are
a show of strength for one of the oldest
Christian bodies in the world The Crisis
began when a group of Rebel Bishops
created their own assembly in oremiah
region saying they face discrimination
under the church's current system they
say their culture and language have been
consistently ignored by the religious
hierarchy accusations the church leaders
have denied
a set of aromo archbishops and Bishops
who who broke away from the Orthodox
church and then the Roma Regional
government was actually helping those
Breakaway Bishops essentially uh take
over the the the Orthodox church and and
put their people in in place violent
protests followed between supporters on
both sides and security forces
the church says at least 30 people have
been killed in a week and access to
social media has been widely restricted
well prime minister Abby Ahmed has asked
his ministers to stay out of the dispute
the government issued a ban on
church-led demonstrations met to oppose
the Breakaway movement
but religious leaders described that
move as a decoration to destroy the
church
this is a really difficult situation for
the Prime Minister his political base uh
being in power has primarily been
between the aroma which is the ethnic
group he comes from and Ethiopia is a
largest ethnic group and the amhara
um uh which has dominated the Ethiopian
Orthodox church
with more than 36 million followers the
Ethiopian Orthodox church has been
around for Centuries with a vast
religious cultural and political
influence for now tensions have
de-escalated but further divisions May
fuel more conflicts that threaten to
extend well beyond the church
Katya Lopez Al Jazeera